hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I've
got a bunch of things to show for you
I've been setting this up for about an
hour and a half and admittedly I had to
use console commands but you'll see why
because there was no alternative for
what I was doing but I needed to start
here in the grand reef because they did
an expansion of the grand reef and they
added quite a few new things mostly
environmental but there actually is a
new creature over here which I don't
remember where I was out here
the reason I'm starting here is because
I didn't even know about this until I
came out here because I came out to get
the nuclear reactor fragments and I just
got the last one so I have the nuclear
reactor which is I'm going to build in
my new base which you guys are gonna see
in a little bit it's not there yet
that's gonna be towards the end of the
episode but what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna show you this first I'm gonna head
back to my main base gather a few more
supplies and then I'm gonna go down see
I've got it I've also got a compass now
so I can actually see where I'm
orienting and I believe I need to go to
the north oh yeah and if you see all
those pulsating things down there don't
worry about that yet we're gonna get to
that later but you may notice that the
symbol is actually different because in
this episode I'm going to show you of
the exosuit which actually isn't a part
of this update but that's why I had to
use console commands because the exosuit
is a new thing that allows for very very
very deep sea exploration up to 1,700
meters now to get that you need a lot of
materials and I might have to use some
more constant commands to get them
because you're not technically supposed
to be able to even get the exosuit but
it's fully animated and it's for the
most part pretty much working correctly
it's not a hundred percent but it's good
enough for our purposes and our purposes
are just exploring the cool new stuff
that's available around here but first I
gotta find these goddamn things I'm not
even gonna try to spoil it before I get
there because they're really cool to see
him when I stumbled across him he was
like what the hell happened to you
what's wrong with you like something
ripped out a half-life 2 and put into
this game it's really cool but let me
see it on I need to gather some of this
stuff this is uh this is urine tonight
you ran denied you ran your your random
tonight a highly radioactive and
interesting material that's what's gonna
be used for the nuclear reactor so I
want to gather up some of it before I go
out there because in the grand reef I
believe it's the only place for this
stuff all this so there it is
hi buddy how you doing
oh man look at him you know what I mean
by it it looks like it was ripped out of
half-life 2 it looks like the Striders
and I believe I'm not remember since
sure about this I did scan one I believe
it was called like the ground Strider
and they're so cool
they're just waving their arms like
they're partying all night long I love
them to death and if you get close to
them they kick you just like this hey
come on
kick me okay great I want you to do it
come on hey what are you doing what are
you doing
bonk that not bother you hey there he
goes wait he's gonna do it you gonna do
it oh sure he bout to do it no you're
not gonna do it why doesn't he want to
kick me maybe it's because I'm not
outside of my ship they do this are you
gonna kick me buddy whoa I'm low on
health careful about that hey hey you're
ugly you're ugly and no one likes you no
huh well usually they were animated
before I swear Oh
your mouth is so bizarre but he's got a
tiny little smile up there that's
adorable
all right fine then but there's a whole
herd of them is what the weird Oh also I
finally uh I finally named mossy moth
bubble butt because I just love that
name and I got him colorized so that
he's all customized over there so I got
the note boat and I got bubble butt but
either way that's what I wanted to show
you and they got this whole like this
whole area here is all built up and
different and if I actually go into this
cave system here it's like it's like a
grand archway and you can't see much of
it at night right now but it's it's it's
a really cool grand archway that you can
barely see the edges of over there and
there's some bioluminescent stuff on the
outskirts of it you can barely see it
over there but it's like a huge like
cavernous tunnel and I don't know what
the purpose of it is in fact I I think
it might have been at one point like
developed or bored through by a giant
creature who knows
cuz there are some giant creatures over
here hi buddy hey hi friend how are you
doing bonk sorry about that sorry friend
I don't even know if these things are
killable yet but they exist and they are
things but either way I got to get back
to I got to get back to my main base
over there so the next thing I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna I'm gonna pause I'm
gonna come back when I'm over there
there's another urine in the night so
I'm gonna get that and then I'll see you
at my base oh and if it wasn't obvious I
built another seamoth see I've been
playing for a long time before this
particular episode because I wanted to
make sure that everything I had was in
working order so that you guys wouldn't
be incredibly disappointed for me and
boy I've got some surprising things to
show you but not until I get done with
this and not until I get everything that
I got going on here and it's it's pretty
cool but first I got to read the name so
thank you everybody who commented down
below and I put them on the lockers over
here
so there's nem eight-to-one who made fun
of my inability to get my CMOS back into
my Cyclops
there's Linus Brewer who made fun of me
and said that if I was swimming around
I'd probably drown so thank you very
much and then there's au tigress foxy oh
I wrote these down I don't have them
anymore but Tigers foxy who gave the
terrifying idea that that skeleton down
in the Lost River like maybe it didn't
die of natural causes maybe it was
killed by something even bigger and
that's a horrifying thought but there
can't have just been one if I know
anything about creatures and their
mommies and daddies it had to have been
birthed or hatched at some point and
there probably was something bigger and
then cos Suton see who said something
very very useful and educational and it
was probably game-changing and probably
gonna make everything wonderful me
throughout the rest of the game but I
can't remember what it was right now so
I'm just gonna drift through as if
everything is fine but anyway there are
three new things that I want to show you
actually they're not even new they've
been around forever and oh damn and I
think I left it in my other base which
I'm gonna show you okay um I built them
but I got a spawn them in now so it will
give me two seconds here okay so I got
them so this is this stasis rifle which
I got the plans for in like the third
episode of this entire series
I just never used it I never made it I
never built it but what's cool about
this and it's just turning daytime so
this is convenient is OOP [ __ ] sorry
ignore that ignore that what you do is
you hold it down you charge it up you
fire this thing out and it creates a
stasis bubble and anything that goes in
this get stopped in its tracks even the
reaper Leviathan can be stopped by this
thing admittedly only for a short period
of time and I'm not under percent sure
how long that is but it will stop it so
what I'm gonna do is to show this off
I'm gonna go over here to these smaller
not Reaper leviathans first and then I'm
gonna go over to the Reaper Leviathan
because I'm my second base is near
another one and it's very dangerous and
I'm probably gonna die from it
oh no this'll do a little ol air sac
it's a perfect candidate for what I'm
about to unleash Lebowski oh no you
can't move Konya oh you can't move
kanya perfect candidate for my new
device which is a propulsion cannon and
the propulsion cannon is another object
that I've had forever and I've just
never built
does this one home sorry there's all god
oh god oh god
the explosion of blood oh no is that it
is that's it is that it's dead corpse
jeez
Wow look at my wacky fingers waggle yeah
oh Jesus I forgot that's something I
need but the propulsion cannon it grabs
up objects and it can even rip limestone
off of the sea walls and it allows you
to grab them or fire Oh which is awfully
convenient and then there's this other
thing called the repulsion cannon which
just propels things now I don't know
what it can propel a maximum of the
propulsion cannon can only grab small
objects but this can push anything huh
boom and it can push it far and I don't
know if it works on a Reaper leviathan
but I know it works on some bigger fish
like give me two seconds here to get
over to the thing like man I spent
forever oh how I miss you safe shallows
I've gone into dangerous territory and I
may never return but I love you I love
all of you come on give me something to
repulse repulsive my horrific ly ugly
face where are you
where'd it go where are those guys did I
did I farm them all to death by
searching for their teeth good god they
seem to be gone well I probably should
have taken my seamoth out anyway cuz
Bubba would have been a lot faster about
this stuff but oh well alright and we're
gonna get to that in a second everyone
just ignore that down there that's not
important right now ignore the fact that
my Cyclops is currently parked 900
meters below the seafloor
everyone ignore that you don't need to
worry about it it's not something you
need to worry about right now okay so
considering I can't exactly test this
repulsion candidate on every any of the
fauna down here in the creepvine forest
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna test it
on a Reaper Leviathan because why the
hell not I may live and die but I'll
know that I'll be fine I guess maybe
probably not gonna be fine where did I
go
I went far out geez where am i [ __ ] am i
oh there I am okay alright but either
way those are the guns I've got some
you're an tonight and ignore that
don't don't mind that thing that that's
not important right now that's not
important don't worry about it it's fine
everybody everybody stop panicking it's
fine okay so I think I got everything
that I need down here so now it's time
to go to my second base and to do that I
got a head nope no that's not no with
that new earth I got a head a bit to the
north and go past this mushroom forest
here because down this mushroom forest
is a familiar place that we've been to a
few times before at the heart of
subnautica wait at the heart of
subnautica in the deepest parts of the
ocean
only death awaits us there lies
something damn it there lies something
deeper and darker than anything we could
possibly imagine I need to move
elsewhere but if I can find it
but before I can find it I I'm gonna be
running into into a reaper Leviathan
because the reaper Leviathan guards the
entrance to the inactive lava zone and
that's where we're headed there have
been some updates down there and I know
this because I've been down there before
this episode started and that's where I
built my new base and that's why I had
to use console commands like I I don't
like to use them but I wouldn't have
been able to haul all the material that
I needed all the way down there to be
able to build that thing sorry about
that oh jeez oh jeez okay so that's the
entrance the big gaping black hole in
the bottom of the ocean but somewhere
round here is a gosh-darn goddamn reaper
love anthem where did you go hello I
know there's one around here and it
shouldn't be this hard to spot him who's
that oh jeez okay I thought that was
another chasm into the darkness
okay so there's usually where's that
ship cuz usually by the ship the crash
ship I thought I would have heard it by
now maybe it wandered off maybe it's
never gonna bother me again maybe I'm
finally free of its tyrannical grip oh
hey how's it going okay okay alright
alright whoa what the [ __ ]
oh Jesus criminy Christmas do I haven't
met thank goodness good golly all right
well let me drink some water
I got a cured oculus right woo I wanted
to eat a last meal before I go after
this [ __ ] alright so okay alright okay
here we go oh jeez oh God
alright charge up
turned up BAM oh that's not far why how
did it do that
ah hey no don't you don't no no you
don't don't don't even think about it
bro
okay so dammit I'm wasting all my power
what is that what is that okay so the
thing about this is goddamn it I'm
running out of oxygen okay so I got to
get a little closer which isn't very
happy for me I don't want to lose bubble
butt over here I really don't want to
lose bubble butt but I gotta get closer
to this thing
Oh God oh jeez Oh spotted me Wow oh jeez
oh jeez oh jeez oh jeez
oh [ __ ] Wow why funny um [ __ ] you
got hit in the head head shot oh geez oh
it's after that sand shark oh that poor
little [ __ ] come here god damn it just
come here
hey um okay that guys getting stasis oh
jeez I almost [ __ ] okay
we're fine get over here you son of an
ass ah geez yeah geez yeah gosh oh man I
didn't think it would be this hard to
get his attention he usually is very
adamant about getting whoo yeah that's
really close oh geez oh geez oh geez oh
crap I got you [ __ ] oh I'm gonna do
this again just in case I got a full
charge in whoa okay whoa look at that oh
not so tough now Bubba ain't ya oh
you're not so tough now huh that's what
I thought I don't know how long this
lasts but I'm gonna overcompensate do it
again I am okay man he is not happy he's
mired oh look at him he's so mired oh he
the maddest okay this is where things
get weird I'm gonna try this huh it
boosts Tim I boost him out of the bubble
[ __ ] but it boost him oh I can boost you
you ain't so tough now huh
I mean you're still pretty tough and
you're probably gonna kill me but I'm
gonna boost the [ __ ] out of you I'm
gonna I'm gonna waggly finger yeah ooh
my proposed encounter is gonna get all
waggly
on you get over here little [ __ ] huh
little [ __ ] baby little [ __ ] baby you
wanna fight me with your muscle
definition down this idea
alright that's right run away run away
like a little baby oh [ __ ] run it away
little baby okay oh he meant be mad hey
my CMOS get rid of it hey let it go
leggo get out here yeah yeah you go get
stasis oh [ __ ]
boy okay let me get a full charge on him
so I can get away I am worried oh he's
so mired oh my oh my seem oh oh my see
Martha caught in the bubble oh God
I've gotten the stasis bubble I [ __ ]
up i taunt 'add i taunted too much i was
playing with fire okay good I'm free
whoo all right you have fun there you
have fun baby boo I'll leave you alone
now
well he would my head oh he gonna be
mired well he shall mired all right so
where am I
I got a little disoriented over here but
I think okay east north I need to go not
north I need to go east okay
oh man that was that was tempting fate
but that was fun I did it I did okay
okay so the black hole entrance should
be somewhere to the left over here is
that it or is that just an unloaded area
I have a funny feeling average is an
unloaded air so just beyond this second
Ridge whoo
those are it works so that's how you do
that so I don't have to be so skewed I
don't want to be skewed did everything
in the ocean anymore
I've got guns now whoo
oh and also I wanted to mention um some
of you may have been confused by the
fact that my seamoth can currently go
down to a thousand meters because they
remove that what I did I have the legacy
version of the I hate going into this
still scary even though I've been down
here a couple times now but I've got the
legacy version of the seamoth pressure
compensator it's the old version which
allows you to go down to a thousand
meters but what I'm gonna do when I get
down there is I'm gonna make the new
version of it which is dear friend oh
wait am I going the right way
this doesn't seem right now that's not
the right way okay I'm gonna make the
new version of it which works with the
exosuit which is gonna allow me to do
even more when I go down there but first
I gotta find my way back here because
it's kind of a kind of a labyrinthian
maze I think this is the entrance over
here and I'm pretty sure I just hang a
right all the way down here see but you
can see they actually they actually
modified the inactive lava zone down
here because you can see that the walls
aren't just that weird bubbly poopy
texture and I appreciate a good bubbly
poopy texture but frankly I'm a little
bit happy that it's nice and actually
looks like underwater sea floor now for
some respect I don't know what
underwater sea floor looks like but
probably not this repeated extra
cavernous tunnel alright
down we go oh geez oh what's that in the
distance you see Oh could it be a hidden
underwater base it definitely could be
and I think I actually went a different
way down here but uh this is terrifying
because you'll see that this is my base
and I built it up pretty good but we're
at 923 meters and I built it on to the
precipice into the deeper deeper depths
like if you see the outline of what's
down there it ain't good and the only
thing the only thing that can go down
there not even my Cyclops which is where
the Frick is my cycle I think it's up
where my Cyclops go where's the no boat
go who took my note boat oh oh there
that's okay there it is there's my note
boat okay there's the Cyclops and here's
my base but what's down below the
Cyclops can't even get to so I have to
pop out real quick here and then I'm not
damn it I keep running oh why am I doing
this I guess
I built a moon pool down here which is
completely illogical ugh it's so deep
it's so deep okay so anyway going in
there welcome aboard
so in here I've got a little base and
the problem with building a base down
here and I've got convenient
illumination from these exosuits out
there which we're gonna get to later
probably in the next episode because I
don't have enough time for this one but
I'm just gonna show you the only problem
with building a base down here is you
don't have any natural sunlight so solar
panels can't cut it
you need I've got eight bioreactors
eight trying to power this whole
sumbitch and it's all off a sprayed fish
pretty much just exclusively Spade fish
because they're pretty high in their
energy output and I've got eight of them
together but that's not enough what I
did and that's why I went to get the
nuclear reactor and that's why we
started in the grand reef and that's why
we're over here nine hundred and thirty
five meters below sea level which is
pretty freaking far so with all that
said the next step that I'm gonna do in
the next episode actually involves
pressure compensators but the new style
of pressure compensator which I've had
in my inventory they're just generic
pressure compensators and they're made
in the the modification station because
they're originally made for the seamoth
and they allow them to go down but that
only allows it go down 300 metres to get
them to go farther you need to upgrade
it to mk2 and mk3 in the modification
station so that is the next step in this
journey but unfortunately I am all out
of time and here are the lovely exosuits
I'll give you a little teaser I'll jump
in the exosuit so you can see
it's actually fully working like it's
it's fully animated not fully animated
but it's run by a power cell
there's no way to craft it right now so
the only way to get it to spawn it in
but it does have an upgrade panel over
here where I have the generic version of
the pressure compensator because it's
base depth is 900 meters but we're just
below Niner to meter so to even get it
to survive I had to put the generic
version of it in there so it's basically
just it's an exosuit it walks around
your walkie walkie your jumpy with the
thrust it doesn't have any swimming
capability it literally just Falls and
lands on the sea floor and then it walks
around which is why it's perfect for
exploring this deeper part once I get
the upgrades in here so we're gonna get
to that in the next episode not in this
one because I do not have enough time
and I'm not ready to go down there just
yet
but it's gonna be terrifying because
next time I'm just gonna do the upgrades
I'm gonna put the upgrades in here and
then I'm gonna leap off I'm gonna leap
off the precipice and I'm just gonna
fall if it's below 70 100 meters down
there I'm [ __ ] we have that to look
forward to either way thank you
everybody so much for watching I don't
know how this is gonna go in the next
episode but we're gonna see so thank you
again everybody and wish me the best of
luck cause I'm gonna need it so thanks
again and as always I'll see you in the
next video
Oh pat me a million times on the back
out